[Music]
hi
it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd and skincare note
who doesn't seem to exist below this
level
but yeah i have a body and today i'm
going to be talking about some of my
best tips for looking after the skin on
your body
if you like nerding out about beauty
click the like the subscribe and click
the notification bell so you don't miss
any videos
skincare for your body is like skincare
for your face in a lot of ways but also
not in a lot of other ways my first tip
is to pick actives for your body
skin care just like you pick actors for
your face skincare
i think a lot of us use lots of actors
on our faces but we sort of ignore our
bodies
but there are lots of really good body
products on the market so i thought i'd
tell you about some of the ones that
i've been using lately
that i've been really liking i'm going
to start with this video sponsor
necessary i talked about their body wash
in my 2019 skincare favorites
i really like it because it's good for
cleansing your skin without stripping it
and it's got this really cute twist top
since then i've also tried some of their
leave-on products so the body serum and
the body lotion
these are the sorts of actives that you
see in face products they're really
minimalist they have really great
textures
and they're fragrance free my skin is
fine with fragrance and i personally
like having a pleasant scent especially
when i'm using body products
but i know a lot of people can't
tolerate fragrance and it can be hard to
find fragrance-free body products
so it's really good that these are
available the texture is also really
light which i love
a lot of body products can be really
heavy and sticky and they take
ages to sink in these three all have
niacinamide which is one of my favorite
skincare ingredients
it's vitamin b3 and it's really good for
sensitive skin there's also my favorite
humectant glycerin which is really good
at keeping your skin hydrated
and it's especially good in cleanses
because it helps prevent your cleanser
from stripping your skin
cleansing is one of the harshest steps
in your routine and
your natural moisturizing factor the nmf
which is naturally in your skin it's a
natural humectant
that can get washed away so having
glycerin in there stops your skin from
getting that tight itchy dry
feeling that you can sometimes get
especially if you like hot showers which
i do
the serum has hyaluronic acid which is
another really good humectant
moisturizer
it can be hard to find body products
that have hyaluronic acid so this is
really good for that
on its own it's already really good but
if you pair it with a lotion to lock in
the moisture
then it sort of supercharges it and it
makes your skin really really hydrated
if you want to try their products you
can use lab muffin 10 for 10
off another brand i really like for body
products is bioderma
they have a lot of really hydrating
really soothing products and they use a
lot of patented technologies in them
i've talked about the shower oil before
which is really really lovely in winter
but it's not available in australia but
this is also really good this is a
shower gel
it's in the attiderm range which is for
really sensitive skin
so this one is fragrance free it's also
got lots of moisturizing humectants and
lipids
it has the skin barrier therapy patient
which protects skin from irritating
bacteria
one of the things i really like about
this is even though it's so good for
sensitive skin
it still foams up i really like foam
because it's easier to distribute and
rinse off
and so this gives you the option for
foam while still being really really
gentle
another brand i really love is qv it's a
bit like the australian version of
cerave
i love that they have really large pack
sizes they're really budget-friendly and
they have these handy pump bottles
this range is really skin friendly
really gentle it's actually supported by
the eczema association of australia
so if you're into hyaluronic acid i have
to mention the hyaluronic concentrate
from dersium's chemistry brand
this is one of their ceo nicolas
favorite products and it's basically
just
a pump of goo it has a really nice pump
dispenser
this is like a sure way to win me over
having a really handy
pump dispenser and this just pumps
straight down which is really nice
this goes for your face as well but i
find it more important for your body
when you're using humectant moisturizers
they really shine when you put occluses
and emollients on top
so a more creamy moisturizer not just a
straight up water-based humectant
moisturizer
and having that combination of different
types of moisturizers really helps
hydrate your skin on multiple levels and
lock it in
i've also been using the ten bum body
lotion from indeed labs over winter this
is just a really nicely formulated body
lotion
it works really well at locking in the
humectants
there are also some products that aren't
specifically made for your body
but they're in pretty big pack sizes and
they're reasonably priced
so there's the ordinary glycolic acid
seven percent toning solution
and pixi's glow tonic these acids also
double up really well as deodorants
so having a low ph in your armpits
changes the
ratio of bacteria that live there and
it's really the bacteria that causes the
smell so they feed off things in your
sweat
and turn that into the bio chemicals
you're probably all going to laugh about
how old this bottle is but this is the
poorest choice clear acne body spray
that i've been refilling
this spray is really awesome if you get
back knee because not only is it a spray
it actually sprays upside down i'm sure
other brands also have this but this is
actually the only one that i know of
one ingredient that i see in body
products but not in a lot of face
products and i wish there were more
is oatmeal oatmeal is in the veno range
and it's named after the vinthromise
which are these really good
anti-inflammatory compounds in oats
it's the reason why oatmeal baths are
really good for itchy body conditions
like chickenpox and eczema
now if you want to go really hardcore
with actives on your body like you would
with your face products
you can get more intense body products
as well
this is from kj body which is an
australian brand
it has pecutial point five percent
retinal point two percent and glycolic
acid
usually you only find this sort of thing
with clinical brands and as you'd expect
it comes with a clinical brand price tag
but if you work out what the price is
per ml it still ends up being an
okay price compared to face products my
next tip is to use face care products
that didn't work on your face
on your body this is like if it broke
you out or if you found a better product
since then
it means that you don't waste all your
money you can use it up quickly before
it expires and chances are this will be
like the most pampering your body's ever
gotten
body skin is generally more resilient
than face skin there's a few extra
layers of dead skin cells in your
stratum corneum there your body skin
also can react to different things so
for example things that break out your
face might not break out your body
if you did have a reaction on your face
though be really careful when you're
using it on your body
try to avoid sensitive areas and try to
avoid broken skin
now let's talk about how to do the
different steps of your routine on your
body
you don't need to cleanse your arms and
legs really really thoroughly
this is official dermatologist advice
check out derma angelo if you haven't
already
now you should still be cleansing your
smelly bits like you're growing and your
armpits
and if you get back acne you should
still be cleansing your back
especially if you use hair conditioner
with heavier conditioners these can clog
up your pores
and you should still be cleansing your
skin if it's dirty so don't say oh
michelle said i didn't have to clean
my skin after like tough mudder if you
have a job where full body hygiene is
really important like if you work in a
p4 lab
this doesn't apply to you and obviously
we should still be washing our hands
really thoroughly
but for most of us most of the time we
don't have to scrub and scrub our arms
and legs until they're squeaky clean
you are probably doing more harm than
good along the same lines you shouldn't
be showering for too long
with too hot water now i know it's
really nice to have a hot shower
sometimes
and i still do it but just know that
having that hot shower having all that
water flowing over your skin
is getting rid of your skin's natural
moisturizing factor the natural
humectants in your skin
this is actually one of the big causes
of upper back itch in winter
people are having showers and that hot
water is just thumping into the upper
back
now for exfoliating your body you can
exfoliate your body just like you do for
your face with the same precautions
body skin is a bit tougher it's a bit
thicker than face skin with a few extra
layers of dead skin cells so that means
it's a bit harder to overexfoliate your
body
but it can still happen the thicker skin
also means that you get more ingrown
hairs and you can get keratosis polaris
or chicken skin
this is when the dead skin cells block
off the hair follicle to deal with this
the best way is to exfoliate and
moisturize because when your skin is
really dry
it doesn't exfoliate itself as well as
well as the chemical exfoliants i talked
about before like glycolic acid that you
use on your face
there's also urea urea shows up in some
face products but it's a lot more common
in body products and it's really good
for exfoliating and moisturizing
especially if you have cracked hands or
cracked heels you can also use a lot of
physical exfoliants so you can use
scrubs for example this is one of my
favorites
it's the smoothie star breakfast scrub
from soap and glory
it smells like maple syrup you can also
make a really effective diy scrub just
by mixing a bit of sugar or salt with
oil
you can also use tools like body mitts
this is one from face halo and you can
use a wet or dry
when it's dry it's a little bit more
efficient if you're trying to really get
into a rough patch
when it's wet it's a lot more gentler
and so that's better for
overall areas on your body there are
also exfoliating towels and these are a
lot more popular in
asia this is one that i got from
innisfree i've also got one from daiso
which is really good
and there's a really popular one called
the italy towel the thing i really like
about these is that it's really good for
scrubbing your back and this is really
important if you have
long hair like me where you use lots and
lots of hair conditioner and that hair
condition tends to clog your pores
the important thing with these tools is
that you need to make sure you let them
dry
properly in between uses because it's
damp and it's probably got some of your
body products in it and it's also got
your dead skin cells
this is a really good breeding ground
for bacteria mold
so make sure you rinse these properly
and let them dry properly so take them
out of your shower maybe even out of
your bathroom
in between uses otherwise if you're
using the dirty tool and you're
scrubbing it into your skin
you can actually introduce the bacteria
mold into your skin and that leads to
infections it's really gross
there are case studies on it so that's
one of the reasons i switch from a
sponge on a stick to
a body towel for my back because with
the body towel it's a lot easier
to unravel it and rinse it out properly
and then also let it dry out a lot
faster
now on the exfoliation topic dark
armpits and knees are normal
you are not necessarily meant to be the
same color all over
this is a eurocentric beauty standard
you have more skin where it's folded so
your knees your armpits your elbows
and more skin means more melanin and
that's why you have a darker patch there
if you have rough hardened skin or dry
scaly patches then exfoliating and
moisturizing can help with that
and yes your skin might get a bit
lighter but if you're a person of color
you're not necessarily meant to have the
same color skin all over
if your skin's in a healthy condition
and it's symmetrical then it is normal
to have fluctuations in color there are
a few conditions where it isn't normal
and is a reflection of an underlying
health issue
and if that's the case you should get it
checked out but otherwise it's just
another unrealistic beauty standard
i know if you just start googling dark
armpits and dark knees and dark elbows
or whatever you end up with all these
scary health conditions
but that's just a reflection of how
the medical system just doesn't quite
have enough info on skin of color
so let's move on to moisturizing the
best time to apply body moisturize is
right after you step out of the shower
when your skin is still damp
when your skin is wet it's most likely
to dry out and so you want to get
moisturizer on there
as quickly as you can it's also really
good to seal in that extra moisture and
so that humectant can grab onto extra
water
it's also a good idea to track your
moles especially if you have lighter
skin
or if you get a lot of sun exposure
there's a really good acronym for
spotting suspicious moles it's abcde
so if you have a mole that's asymmetric
with a fuzzy border
if it's got uneven color if it's bigger
than a pencil eraser
or if it's been changing in appearance
then these are all features
that you should get checked out so you
should go to a doctor and ask them to
look at your mole
and maybe take a biopsy in australia
it's recommended that you have an annual
all-over body mold check
and usually your gp can do this there
are apps that can help you track moles
and these can be really useful
but don't rely on them 100 because it's
still pretty new technology
it doesn't necessarily work for all
sorts of cancerous moles
or all skin types for your body of
course we also need to talk about
sun protection this is especially the
case if you're exfoliating with alpha
hydroxy acids which can make your skin
more sensitive to the sun
or if you're using really expensive
anti-aging actives on your skin
it's a waste of money if you're not also
protecting your skin from further damage
so check the uv index to see if you need
to protect your skin i have another
video on upf clothing and how to pick
normal clothes that protect you from uv
if you're using sunscreen make sure you
use enough so the recommendation is one
teaspoon for the front of your torso one
for the back of your torso
one for each limb and one for your face
and ears and neck so i hope you found
this video useful share your best body
tips in the comments
if you liked it you can click the like
and subscribe for more videos like this
you can follow me on instagram at lab
muffin beauty science and check out my
blog for more nerdy beauty content
see you next time
you